Well,
even if we're gone If you
eat and sleep unexpectedly in a long-distance love, you won't die And you
'll find other important things
I'm going to live with
my
heart  Two or
three people are going to have fun with tricks Do
n't recommend being dishonest
Look,
love and marriage are sexual skills
You've accomplished the god-slaying by singing close to the God of Light
If you say so, you'll follow a turbulent fate,
right?
There will be times when you lose money, there will be times when
you'll be unreasonably blamed, won't you?
No, but
still
, love people,
do good
deeds, don't be afraid
, build rather than destroy
, give forgiveness for your cargo, hope for despair, joy for sorrow,
and protect the weak from every boy.
Beer Area 6
Brad and I are also cute
The blessings of the good gods will always be with you
Below is the following
, believing in the result and carrying forward
without dividing  If you have one thing, you can put anything on and get
started You're a
bit of a thinker, but
don't stop worrying too much about what the
two of you were
saying I'll never forget it I'm
sure I won't forget
it It's like God's friend fishing
I'm sure it will shine a light on my fault So
,
uh, did you come in early me ani?
The strength and richness of the scent was reminiscent of
[music]